but we're going to begin this hour with
a not so Bravo topic we're talking about
jobs uh and a major hiring crisis a
problem really bigger and older than the
great resignation you've heard so much
about it's a problem you're not going to
find in the unemployment rate which is
of course that near record lows and it's
because a large number of American men
in particular men in their Prime working
years are actually not working and
they're not even looking for work the
result is a bit of a mystery and also a
major hole in the American economy
my name is Mike Rowe and this
it's my job of all the jobs he's done
over the past 20 years now get ready to
get dirty and Mike Rowe has done them
all as a host of Dirty Jobs on Discovery
from from She's the dump oh now it's
dirty jobs isn't it the hoses that suck
cheap he's never claimed to be an
economist thank you but while taping the
series during the Great Recession of
2008 he did notice something important
to get all anybody was talking about was
the number of people who are out of work
but on Dirty Jobs even then everywhere
we went we saw Help Wanted signs it
turns out dozens of real-life economists
and other researchers have a possible
explanation a long-term decline in male
labor force participation or as one
Think Tank summarized it men not at work
this is a men Problem by and large right
seems to be look back to the 1950s and
98 percent of men in their so-called
Prime working years had a job or were
looking for one that number has fallen
ever since to the point where today more
than 7 million men have essentially
dropped out of the workforce we've given
a lot of people a lot of options
and Incredibly one of those options is
do nothing
Rowe and I met at Empire metal a
fabrication and finishing shop in Queens
New York and where much like
manufacturing shops Nationwide finding
skilled workers like these is a growing
challenge we have more jobs than we have
people four about one and a half jobs
for every one worker Jay Timmons who
leads the National Association of
Manufacturers describes all this as a
profound problem for the companies he
represents 99.9 percent of them will say
that their number one challenge right
now is being able to fill those open
jobs so you are here as a representative
of more than 14 000 manufacturers in
these United States and the number one
problem for 99 out of 100 of them is
filling jobs yeah
I never thought I'd be able to say that
but now it's kind of an all hands on
deck we've got to fill these jobs that
are open and there are nearly 800 000 of
those jobs open right now according to
the latest Federal counts a number that
surged in recent years as companies
reinvest in American-made products or
try to anyway and with manufacturing
workers earning more than thirty dollars
an hour on average Timmons says the
problem is not pay but perception used
to be dirty dark and dangerous today
it's very Sleek it's very technology
driven and that's what we saw when we
visited electrosoft a company outside
Philadelphia that makes circuit boards
for everything from missiles to
submarines so over there is the quality
area where we do first piece article
testing final testing but CEO Carla
trotman says they could be doing more if
only she had the workers to do it how
many people work here right now 30. how
many people do you wish worked here
right now 45. so you have 15 people that
you have jobs for yes but you can't find
them cannot how much money
in Lost business is there in not being
able to hire the people that you want
around 5 million
in top line revenue five million yeah
that would be here and that presumably
you'd be paying taxes on obviously and
that would go into people's pockets and
would be going out in a broader economy
yeah what is your theory about where
those 15 people are right now I honestly
have no idea where they are she suspects
some people may be sitting out because
of a recent change in the way many of us
look at work I think it's fulfillment I
think it's culture I think people really
want to feel as though they are
appreciated I mean Beyonce's song she
said release your job a lot of people
release their jobs you know and they
realize I mean it's an overall feeling
of being fed up yeah and being taken for
granted but there's more according to
one Economist some non-working men face
a skills mismatch a third have criminal
records making them ineligible for many
jobs and making employers hesitant to
hire them and many rely on safety nets
such as disability so you may wonder
what are these guys do doing instead of
work well kind of what you might expect
spending nearly seven hours each weekday
on average relaxing playing games and
watching TV so how is it from where
you're sitting from your understanding
that people can do nothing all day and
still have enough money for a bag of
chips oh well it's almost as though some
entity is paying them it's almost as if
somebody is not letting them fail it's
as if some giant parent somewhere has an
uncle maybe could be a rich Uncle yes
could be a very wealthy uncle
or it might come down to values as many
public schools have stopped offering
shop class many students have stopped
even considering jobs like the ones row
is spotlighted dirty or otherwise it
goes back to the stigmas and stereotypes
and myths and misperceptions that are
keeping guidance counselors from talking
about opportunities like this to the
kids in their care it's those things
that are keeping parents from putting
all the options on the table how big of
an issue is it
to have this many people sitting on the
sideline it's only a matter of our
national identity
I think it's a giant issue and by the
time we realize how big an issue it is
we're gonna have a hard time turning the
temperature down
fascinating story seven million men and
they're watching seven additional hours
I was going to say that relaxing yeah
that figure got me are the women in
their lives or their Partners in their
lives working so this is where it gets a
little bit political people on the right
will say these guys are just living off
government largest they're getting
disability they're benefiting from Aid
and that's got to be reformed and people
on the left say they just need to be
trained up and yeah in the meantime
they're living at home or they're
depending on Partners you you mentioned
this uh skills mismatch and it just made
me think you know my grandfather was a
machinist which is a highly skilled job
not anybody you have to be trained to do
that and I don't know a lot of
machinists now uh in in 2023 and I
wonder if people are being trained for
that and he mentions Mike so micro has a
foundation called micro Works where he
does give people scholarships for that
kind of training that's part of the
issue but like Carla trotman the woman
in Philadelphia runs the uh circuit
board manufacturing facility she'll
train you herself if you're in the
Philadelphia area they're looking for 15
people there it pays well it's a nice
clean quiet place to work
um so go there uh by the way some people
think oh maybe these guys are doing more
stay-at-home dading that's an optimistic
they're not you I looked at the numbers
Shauna Thomas our executive producer
brought this up in fact these guys who
are not working and not looking for work
are spending less time caring for other
household members than the guys who are
at work so they're doing less child care
not even a little bit more I don't know
but an able-bodied man who can work and
doesn't it's not attractive
not attractive and on that note okay I'm
just saying saying for a friend